yep when low and welcome to this video
and plane each s yes okay and I forgot a
French yeah why not let's do something
different for a moment and 93 and it's
an uncommon move in this particular
situation huh hmm why is it an uncommon
move wait if I do this I wonder if I
just well I can play should be form and
then trade on the tool okay I can also
take on a three and give the check which
will probably either trade Queens on win
8 three okay I'm not sure about this but
it's an interesting try yeah he goes for
the Queen trade huh I actually don't
mind if the knight comes to a five so I
let him take if he it's up for it you
know would be one that makes a lot of
sense probably okay be six I would get
the trade in anyway so I don't mind that
the queen is a little bit weird here
yeah I'm not really sure that all this
was a great idea
with it capture and Queen a5 but
interesting yeah he's going to go well
if I go night here now
he cannot cancel because then I will win
deform I actually threaten now too windy
for crime yeah this now I can at least
capture oh wait does he threaten
something Bishop c3 or any no I probably
still can do this it's a useful move I
just want him yeah I mean he cannot
castle which is looking like the most
normal move that would drop deform and
what is a useful move for him rook c1
maybe then I can still take only two I
mean yeah where this gives me a 3 ok
yeah to a for a 47 that's the thing he
seven looks a little bit safer
young
okay I do this he will take a play
Bishop to b4 okay okay maybe that
straight this
it's slightly awkward for him and maybe
he has to take but then I get castles
and Knight takes Queen takes castles I
Castle myself I'm also taking g2 at this
moment I don't think he can play
whatever okay he says he can play
whatever almost at least so but I can't
flick this in and now take with the rook
yes there is Bishop before but Queen h4
looks like he could reply to that yeah
yeah I cannot Castle and that's it's
still probably the case I can do this
give myself f7 for the Queen
yeah that's not too bad I think pawn
takes the screen to age six which is
potentially a problem yeah not so happy
about the queen capture okay I have to
be a little bit quicker him I mean now
just King to f7 and rook c8 this on the
agenda next prevents it prevents it okay
[Music]
having a look at see - yeah I cannot
shake him there unfortunately
[Music]
I mean it's a bit I wanted I want to try
don't want to make it draw it looks a
little bit dangerous for me and the time
is not great but still
he's got Queen III unfortunately which I
didn't really I had Bishop b5 here that
was a lot better actually
in comparison Queen takes I can take I
cannot take that do you see how people
see that like in a fraction of a second
with the rating of two thousand Quincy
eight and queen f8 and everything I'm
toast they're crazy
I've no I really don't get it sometimes
anyway like in no time on the clock and
he sees everything
yeah I mean it's it's okay played a good
game at the end but you know here I'm
still okay with after b5 I'm in trouble
I'm in trouble on the dark squares I
really am around here I'm just winning
which it's not it's not super easy to do
yeah I'm really not sure about this is
couch I don't know 93 is a very weird
move actually but should be too is what
they all play or a3 in some cases 93 is
a bit strange but it's not something
that can be immediately refuted it
should be for it's not bad yeah just
trade does that was something that I
thought like because I'm not unhappy in
something in a situation like that if
the dark squared Bishop is traded it is
a good bishop but I'm not unhappy about
its rate in general I got a bit more
space there to maneuver and this is some
not that I'm not bad to have okay
whatever I did it differently
and plate for this which more or less I
mean not what I thought this is actually
interesting and the engine agrees just
to give up that corn that he didn't do
it I mean this could be some sort of
compensation the dark squares my queen
is a bit of anyway there was a good move
and I think we're talking about a
roughly equal position here that is
confirmed by the computer yeah okay I
snatched that pawn and it's roughly here
I should I should be fine right
yeah Bishop c6 is not great and she
wants to take I'm a bit surprised like
here it gives me an advantage maybe I
really don't understand chess why should
what be better I mean I can understand
that maybe it's compensation but better
really yeah I mean I never understood
the French defense
now can a the root lift maybe yeah after
this I should be winning and you know
it's more or less what the engine says
it gives G 6 mm yeah maybe I can afford
that but not let's not a move that you
make that easily anyway um but my
standards I was doing okay
before okay and she wants to go h 5 try
it I know this one okay and I'm having
this and does I can yeah that's better
okay I what's not unhappy here I mean it
still looks like I should wait mom then
I played here and this should lose if
I've loses the house okay I didn't see
them overall it's not super obvious I
mean now in the engine points you to it
it's kind of clear that this works but
III then came to the age and then you
take the same okay but Bishop Bishop a4
is still a complete win if I play
correctly if I've yeah and bed that was
bad yeah look see to here and now b5 is
just bad b5 is just a bad move I really
panicked somehow B should be 5 is still
ok at this and after that and now white
seems to win with a couple of moves
rooks III was still ok it seems
oh I'm such an idiot I'm such an idiot
oh my god I can just take the friggin
look I had a complete hallucination down
I was really completely believing him
here you know what I was seeing
I was really seeing this that I'm losing
the Queen but of obviously not and he
can just take this and he's totally lost
after this quite obviously oh wow I had
a completely loosen ation down
I was extremely stupid yeah that's how I
lose my games and it's how I lose the
Blitz games but extremely stupid stuff
like that Wow okay so he didn't do
anything great I just had a complete I
just had a complete brain brain-dead
moment down I was really thinking that
somehow he spotted that I lose the Queen
back but that's a completely that's
completely wrong God what am I was what
I was thinking anyway next game should
be will be maybe better thanks for
watching